face à la crise du coronavirus l'état
met la main au portefeuille
il injecte sous forme de prêt des
centaines de milliards d'euros dans le
secteur privé pour éviter les faillites
et ce n'est pas la première fois
souvenez vous en 2008
notre réponse à la crise c'est
l'investissement au total un plan de
relance de 26 milliards d'euros avec des
mesures phare comme la prime à la casse
pour sauver le marché automobile mais
l'état va aller plus loin en injectant
directement de l'argent dans le secteur
privé
exemple en octobre 2008 quelques
semaines après le début de la crise
l'état va injecter 10 milliards et demi
d'euros dans les six principaux
établissements privés y compris ceux qui
n'avaient pas de problème a priori le
but maintenir le robinet à crédit et
donc soutenir la consommation
mais l'état ne s'arrête pas là il ya
quelques semaines l'état voler au
secours des banques aujourd'hui il est
au chevet du secteur automobile au total
six milliards d'euros de prêts sur cinq
ans pour psa et renault
mais cet argent public n'est pas
distribuée sans contrepartie tout comme
aujourd'hui bruno le maire a promis
d'exclure les aides publiques pour les
entreprises basées dans les paradis
fiscaux en 2008 aussi ils s'embêtent y
avoir un code de bonne conduite
en échange de cet argent public les
banques elles ont des obligations
éthiques
pas de parachutes dorés pour les
dirigeants et pas d'argent qui circule
dans les paradis fiscaux
pas de prime de départ exorbitantes pour
les banquiers pas de délocalisation ni
de fermetures d usines pour les
constructeurs automobiles et dans un
premier temps les concernés faisait
profil bas
exemple au forum économique de davos en
janvier 2009 les chefs d'entreprise
juqu'en qui sont très humble cette année
parce qu'ils ne savent pas ce qui va se
passer et ils se rendent compte que
c'est que les gouvernements qui peuvent
et les aider de s'en sortir
deux ans après la crise le chômage frôle
les 10% en france
mais les banques elles été remis sur
pied manifestement les banques se
remettent de la crise beaucoup plus vite
que les particuliers bnp paribas ouvre
le bal de la publication des résultats
pour l'année 2009 et ils sont plus
qu'excellents les bénéfices frôlé les 6
milliards d'euros d'après un rapport de
la fédération bancaire française datant
de 2015
l'état aurait même gagné dans le
sauvetage bancaire 2,3 milliards d'euros
d'intérêts mais ce que la fédération ne
dit pas ce sont les coupes budgétaires
de l'état
l'austérité imposée aux français avec
pour conséquence une augmentation du
chômage des faillites et des situations
sociales dégradées
[Musique]